con ăn thô thì sẽ thông Minh hơn
các bà nhất định phải biết cái sự thật về ăn thô này
mà chưa AI nói với các bà
khi mà em bé của bà nó bắt đầu ăn thô
cơ thể nó không chỉ ăn
mà nó bước vào một cái giai đoạn
hoạt hóa sinh học rất là mạnh
các bà biết những cái em bé mà nó bị ờ não
úng tủy không
tức là não bộ của nó có vấn đề và nó không thể nào
mà thực hiện cái hoạt động
cầm nắm thức ăn để Cho vào miệng và nó không thể
điều khiển những cái cơ
cơ hàm này cơ lưỡi
để em bé nó có thể thực hiện được
cái hoạt động nhai và nuốt được
là ở đây nó tác động xuống đây
và tất cả những cái hoạt động ở dưới này
nó sẽ tác động ngược lên trên
và giúp Cho cái não bộ của em bé
nó là một cái sự phối hợp nhịp nhàng giữa trung
tâm và ngoại VI
giữa cái sự điều hành của não bộ và cái cơ chế feedback
khi mà con của mình nó ăn thô
cái sự nhai của em bé này
cái sự đá lưỡi của em bé
khi mà có thức ăn ở trong miệng này
cái lực cắn của em bé này
cái sự cái cái sự co bóp của cái cơ hàm này
nó sẽ kết hợp với
cái xung thần kinh ở Thùy não trán trước
giúp Cho em bé dán tiếp phát triển cái vận động tinh
và phát triển não bộ
cũng như là cái sự điều hành của não bộ
đối với một loạt những cái hành động em bé
khi mà em bé nó cầm cái thức ăn nó bốc cái thức ăn này
nó sẽ phát triển
bình thường khi mà em bé nó mới 6 tháng đấy
cầm cả cái miếng thức ăn đấy
nhưng mà khi mình Cho ăn thôi trong thời gian dài
thì em bé nó sẽ có thể điều khiển được các ngón Tay này
và một loạt những cái hành động khi mà em bé nó sắp xếp
nó cầm thức ăn
nó đưa lên miệng và cái lực cắn của nó và nó nhai và
nó sẽ là một loạt những cái hành động sắp xếp
giúp Cho não bộ của em bé nó học cách điều hành
và sắp xếp các
thứ tự khi mà mình làm một cái việc gì đó
giúp phát triển não bộ tốt hơn
ngoài Ra khi mà em bé nó ăn thô với cái độ thô phù hợp
thì cái cấu trúc thức ăn nó đa dạng
sẽ giúp Cho cái hệ VI sinh đường ruột nó được phát
triển rất là tốt
và cái hệ VI sinh đường ruột này nó sẽ giúp
sản sinh Ra một số những cái
axit béo chuỗi ngắn
cái axit đỏ chuối ngắn này nó sẽ
tham gia kích thích sản xuất
các chất dẫn truyền thần kinh như là serotonin
90% serotonin nó sản xuất ở ruột
các chất này thì đi Theo trục ruột
não và ảnh hưởng trực tiếp đến cảm xúc của em bé
khả năng học hỏi và ghi nhớ của em bé về sau này
ngoài Ra á cái quá trình nhai
nó còn kích thích não bộ
tiết Ra những cái yếu tố tăng trưởng thần kinh như là bdnf
cái yếu tố tăng trưởng thần kinh
nó là một cái chất giúp Cho cái
cái tế bào thần kinh của em bé nó phát triển và kết nối
bé của mình nó ăn đầy đủ và đa dạng các nhóm chất thì nó sẽ
giúp hấp thu được sắt này
kẽm này ma dê và một số những cái chất khác
để giúp phát triển cái hệ thống thần kinh của em bé tốt nha
khi mà em bé của mình nó ăn thô ấy thì cái lưỡi
cái cơ lưỡi của nó nó được phát triển
nó đá qua đá lại làm thế nào đấy nó nuốt được
thì cái việc mà cứ liên tục
hoạt động liên tục để học cách phát triển
như vậy nó sẽ giúp Cho em bé của mình nó bật âm
nó bật âm sớm và bật âm tốt hơn
có nghĩa là em bé của mình có thể nói sớm hơn
tốt hơn nếu như mà mình Cho em bé nó ăn thô đúng và phù hợp
nếu như đường ruột của em bé nó chưa sẵn sàng
thì đương nhiên là mình chưa Cho em bé ăn thô rồi
nhưng mà khi mà đường ruột em bé nó đã sẵn sàng rồi
các bà cần phải
tập tăng thô Cho em bé
mình phải chấp nhận rằng em bé nó sẽ nôn nó sẽ oẹ
trong những cái lúc đầu khi mà mình tăng thô
thì cái video sau
tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các bà để em bé nó vẫn ăn thô tốt
và vẫn lên cân tốt